villareal est grande voilà monsieur
castro qui arrivent mais bien l'avouer
ah oui
c
davy les gorilles autour de lui ça doit
y faire quelque chose en quand même
cette marque d'affection et louis pierre
trudeau sont connus en 1976 sa première
fois qu'un leader de l'otan ont aperçu
au premier ce mouvement unitaire de
l'otan se rendait à cuba en corée à 1015
temps plein en bas comparé ce week end
être une bonne relation 1er mai comme
journée derrière qui suit avec ville
alain castet et éduqués par des jésuites
également comme pierre trudeau y sont
revus par la suite ils sont revus par la
suite et ils ont gardé des contacts
fréquents parce que
les amis personnels de monsieur trudeau
qui est bien connu le sénateur hubert
passe beaucoup de temps dans l'île de
cuba
c'est ça fleurait de lui c'est là où il
prend ses vacances et il garde un
contact continu avec
monsieur castro et il faut dire aussi
que la personne la présence de monsieur
castro aujourd'hui est très symbolique
c'est un peu si vous voulez le
témoignage de la présence du car est
quand même qu'ils aient une image là
quelque chose c'est parce qu'à une
poignée de main et en appuyant clinton
et castro est un jeune attaquant peu et
castro ça c'est vraiment exceptionnel
que vous voyez au saas et dans les
annales
alors ce très douce très heureux de voir
ça que finalement il peut y avoir en
principe quand on deux personnes veulent
se parler il ya déjà un début la mort ce
de dialogue et possiblement peut-être
une solution éventuellement à tout ça
parce que la police mène et irrationnel
et destructrice l'égard de cuba ça le
fait que renforcer les quatre premiers
d'accord là dessus c'est brice
d'entraîneur mais choisir son sac un
truc encore une fois fait son oeuvre de
gamme intermédiaire sa part annoncé hit
on peut offrir des vins d'ouvrir les
yeux pour voir ce qu'on pouvait ce drame
il faisait allusion tantôt ce que nous
avons vécu au début des années 60 les
menaces de guerre nucléaire centré sur
cuba et américains et voir ça
aujourd'hui à montréal à l'église notre
dame
je crois que c'est un mauvais moment